[Music]
three
two one action hey guys welcome back to
off the record where we talk about
whatever we want
that is he david
i mean it's all right absolutely not but
now i'm just kidding doesn't this feel
like old school jk now
with the whole old school group yeah
ma'am what's up y'all
i took your seat oh that's true no
that's my original cd that's you you
used to be over there when you were the
rare one
but now you're the og one now and he's
the rare one
i know dude pokemon in the wild baby
why would you do that with your luck
that [ __ ] almost landed in your eye
oh it did i just pulled it out right
there you think he gets reversed
like he gets good luck during mercury
retrograde
did you just just say your bike got
stolen someone checks this out so this
[ __ ]
two thousand dollar bike two thousand
dollar bike
so this is what happened so this month
last month my [ __ ] dog got jacked
back at home what your dog got stolen
are you talking about booney let me tell
you about the [ __ ]
yes you [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Laughter]
so uh the most cantastic thing happened
to me
he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] you're a [ __ ] yeah
so my parents have my dog back at home
in sacramento right
uh we don't really have a yard here and
then we have a bunch of dogs so she's a
lot happier there was this boonie this
is booney
so my mom decides that
she just got a cataract surgery so she
was kind of a little bit all over the
place
luke she had cadillac yeah she got
cadillacs so she couldn't see booney
yeah she couldn't see [ __ ]
but uh her vision was you know after
surgery you get a little fuzzy or
whatever right
so they usually take two dogs that we
have to work because they don't get
along well with the other dogs um for
some [ __ ] reason my parents
didn't realize that they didn't have a
dog with them and it was my dog oh [ __ ]
and so so they go to work at 10 and they
leave at six they found out at six the
dog wasn't there
and i was like eight hours and wait how
many dogs do they have six total oh
they're like little dogs that's a lot of
guys that's a lot to keep track of
well the other four on the back just
[ __ ] each other all the time so the
other two
they take with them and so my mom was
calls me up and she goes
you know she sounds a little worried and
sad and i'm like what's going on and she
goes
i lost your dog yeah at first you kind
of just like
it sucks losing a dog she goes yeah it's
like six o'clock i don't know where she
is so for eight hours you didn't know
that you had a dog missing
and they're usually at the store and
she's usually on her lap she goes yeah i
i don't know like maybe i'm getting old
like no it's not cause you're old like
what happened
and so my dog decides that she just
wanted to go off on a little adventure
right and so she she ends up at an
o'reilly's in this area
was that an o'reilly's and one of the
employees saw her and there's a lady on
a facebook group that's known to
quote-unquote rescue dogs
so she gets my dog right we found this
out through a bunch of fans thank you
very much
fans are the best when it comes to
investigating they're like is this your
dog and i wasn't sure at first because
she had the [ __ ] ugliest haircut i'm
like that [ __ ] rat is not my dog
so i wasn't sure if it was but then i
called my dad like did you
did you give my dog a [ __ ] up haircut
so you're even double pissed now
like she's lost as she's well because it
makes sense why she ran away because
she's [ __ ] hiding
so i called my dad did you give booty a
haircut and she
goes yeah i just shaved her yesterday i
was like no wonder she ran away you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
but she saved her yeah he shaved her
down it's hot and so we call her up
we're like hey
um you may have been getting a lot of
phone calls because uh
a lot of people have been calling for
that dog for me right then i gave her
the whole story in the background she
was like i don't believe you and i'm
like there's a lot of people out there
stealing dogs right now to sell dogs i
was like
that dog is hideous all right now i was
like who the [ __ ] is gonna buy this dog
i'm like
okay i understand like maybe she's
really co you know cautious or whatever
so i started sending her photos started
telling her about the dog how they're
like it's different dogs
that's my [ __ ] but then the only picture
i had was her with long [ __ ] hair
but then i was telling her like okay
what we can do is a very simple solution
i was like
at your convenience can my parents their
70 year old [ __ ] korean people
meet you up and then you could see if
it's you're done she goes well i don't
think that's a good idea because what if
you're lying and i'm like okay
you are and i'm getting [ __ ] livid at
this point right especially
because she wants to keep the doctor
well this is the this is the comment
that pissed me off she goes well if it
was my dog this would have never
happened yep and that's when the [ __ ]
veins started coming out she started
telling me about the chip and
then she did it yeah and then she was
like and at this point i started getting
mad so mario steps in and
you know mario's being very cordial very
nice and then finally after about like
two hours on the phone she goes yeah i
think
two hours two [ __ ] hours right let me
tell you about that's a waste
so two hours on the phone and you know
she starts talking to us about her faith
about in christianity and listen i'm
christian too [ __ ] [ __ ] you
[Laughter]
go to hell jesus would give the dog back
that's what i'm saying dude
so at this point you know mariel's being
very nice and she's talking to and she's
like
showing us videos of her dogs or
whatever i'm like [ __ ] i don't give a
[ __ ] about you
give me my [ __ ] dog back right so i'm
already pissed off mario's dealing with
her and she's finally agrees to like
okay she goes i'll give your dog back
under the condition that under the
condition what my
she goes under the condition that you
come with me and we chip her together if
not you're not getting your dog back
[ __ ] you you [ __ ]
she's like reprimanding you exactly and
i'm like [ __ ] i will
[ __ ] punch you in your [ __ ] like i'm
getting it hurts david
clam slam this [ __ ]
obviously mariel is a lot more
level-headed than i am so she's talking
to this whole thing so the next day
um i'm like so we we hit up called up a
few vets in the area right and they're
like
call the cops on her like she cannot do
this that's what the vets were telling
us
she said they cannot she cannot keep
your dog hostage she can't make
conditions like that they're like we're
not gonna do this
because you don't have to do this at all
call the cop every [ __ ] person told
us to call the cops on her
and so but that doesn't help our
situation because she has my dog
so we just told her like look uh no
can't the swat team come and kick the
door down
rescue the dog dog swat that'd be so
dope all the canines come in
oh you pictured all the dogs
yeah so at this point uh she decided to
give our dogs back and then meet up my
parents and return her back
so i we finally got the dog back but she
i don't understand how people
how she can go out of her way too she's
better than you she's power tripping
right i mean she look i mean it's that
self-righteous mentality of like
oh my god i would have never let my see
there's so many people that abuse their
dogs
and then she sees everybody as
wrongdoers and her life must be in
shambles
so her life is a little up she started
telling us her personal life and stuff
like that but here's the thing though
this is what i don't understand about
people this is a very simple concept
it's not whether you're right or wrong
but there's a certain way to say things
and not to say things right it's tactful
yeah it's
it's about tact you can be right but you
have to look at the time and place in
the situation and she doesn't understand
it i just want
you're in distress yeah i just lost my
[ __ ] dog and now you're telling me
that i'm a bad owner because i didn't
[ __ ] my [ __ ] dog
[ __ ] suck my [ __ ] dick you know i
don't think she's interacting with you
though i think
karen's are interacting with themselves
in their own problems it's [ __ ] weird
yeah
they're living they're living in a
delusion everyone else is stupid
and they need to correct it they need to
correct this wrong world
yeah and i just it was i mean thank god
for mario because she's a lot more level
headed than i am because
i i was just [ __ ] angry yeah i mean
if you call the cops on her
you know she's she's gonna act like this
martyr and like
it's like she's such a self-righteous
[ __ ] if someone took my dog or my cat i
would go
john wick on them for sure it's like
okay you don't want to give me back my
doctor
i want to see that movie immediately
dude i want to see
you just break the [ __ ] floor there's
gold coins oh [ __ ]
he's like what are you doing we don't
have gold coins it's just pikes
we only have bitcoin the [ __ ] water
starts spraying out
what the [ __ ] is going on i have i'm in
a frame on my
on my bed stand dead now yeah but that
happened and then somebody stole my
[ __ ] bike
so i've kind of just learned you're not
allowed to have nice i don't think that
was a self-righteous move though
i think that was just a selfie that's a
jack that's a jackpot [ __ ]
give me that bike you know biking has
been super [ __ ] fun for me though so
like when that bike was gone i
actually understood why people get sad
when they lose their bike
oh spend two thousand dollars on it
that's true too
that's uh that's expensive like the bike
was something that i think during
quarantine gave me a lot of sanity
me too we're not going anywhere i'm not
doing anything so
at that point number one it was my
cardio because i tore my medicines did
you get it fixed yet
uh good for you i'm happy to hear it i'm
getting
but i do not i don't want to be
non-active for about a month or two so
i'm going to get a prp shot instead so
that's what kobe got rest in
i'm gonna do what peace do you sloppy
drunk kiss him
oh my god my guy i don't know but uh
yeah so i'm gonna try to get a prp shot
because i heard that's what kobe bryant
did and it helped his name
he had a meniscus too uh he had poor
olive [ __ ] but the rest of his body is
made out of man no no no no no
the rest of your body is all made out of
other failing parts
dude he called you a human hot dog
sucka i am a human hot dog but i heard
prp works and
i'm one step away from lebron so just
come up see that
oh i didn't see him he got faster and
he's he's
he's he lost a lot of weight since the
last time he came to jake gonna [ __ ]
mess up your ankle again i actually kind
of hurt a little bit
it's easier to get faster when you're
slow oh really what you're trying to box
right now
[Music]
tell you right now i will box every
female in this room
everything i will [ __ ] up every female
just with females
let's [ __ ] go we'll put on headgear
and a mouthpiece only for me
bart has a [ __ ] now no he does not i
mean so we could box him but that was a
very weird insult
why'd you diss him at the same time you
know i think i think that would be a
pretty good
that would be a pretty good movie to
make if only someone here
went to film school like legit and we
were able to get
a movie made that movie would be on
point like david
fighting every jk woman oh dude i would
love let's start with this [ __ ] first
and then all face punches just grab the
back of the head because one of the
dopest movies david one of the dopest
movie schools film schools in the
universe is full sail our very own casey
went there
yeah and this video is brought to you by
full sail
full sail university baby located just
outside of orlando full cell university
offers associates
bachelors and master's degrees designed
for the world of filmmaking
music gaming art and technology offered
both online and on campus these programs
are accelerated so you can earn a degree
in half the time like casey did
degrees are immersive and hands-on so
you can learn your craft using the same
tools and technologies found in the
industry full sail grads are able to
come back and
audit classes throughout their careers
and receive lifetime career development
support
throughout their professional journey
full-sail grads have gone on to do big
things
like working at jk from mixing hit
records
to working on major hollywood films to
winning oscars grammys and more like jk
films
enrolled students receive a laptop along
with industry software
at a deep institution account that
sounds pretty legit
you go to school get a laptop to learn
more about full sales programs as well
as potential
scholarship opportunities visit
wholesale.edu
off the record that's fullsale.edu slash
off the wrecker ever ever ever after the
record you want to start with me first
huh yeah i would love to punch you in
the [ __ ] face
oh let's go do you have anger towards
women
yes i do i hate them you guys should
have never been like an infomercial
hey do you have anger towards women
well step right up because you have your
very own chance to beat them
you're like a cheap indian girl do you
have anger towards women
you have a good thoughts women do you
like to eat
do you like to bake them to bob your
hair if i come and do you like to hate
me
you get angry i do want to see her take
some boxing though
she would be great got some crazy arm
length yeah but she's too much of a
[ __ ] [ __ ] though am i right
we did the class remember we were with
you guys one
class i wanted to give you guys geo is
the [ __ ] but you're the one that only
wants to fight women
[Music]
what's the problem with that equal
[ __ ] rights [ __ ] everybody can get
it except for men
i said [ __ ] could take a good beating
that's right oh yeah i like that dude
they're stronger she's so [ __ ]
annoying
it's so funny because you could tell she
has a hyper competitive side because
when we did that kickboxing
there was a certain point where i was
partnering up with her right and when
you when you first start something you
could kind of like slow down the start
she goes no i don't do that stuff i just
go right here
she just refuses to slow things down
because she has this hyper competitive
side of her
it's [ __ ] hilarious i just hate you
no no no
no no no no no no i just hate you you
don't date
you don't hate you don't date you're
daunting did you guys
watch uh so like the way mma is going
right now boxing or kickboxing like the
girls
are getting [ __ ] good and their
normal training partners
are dudes now so remember that one fight
with the girl with
like the really swollen young jade check
that was a good fight that was a good
fight right dude she looked like the
elephant man that [ __ ] was holy he
looked wide
would you guys would you guys be down to
like have a guy and girl like like we're
back in the there's that one tennis
match right to see what the best
yeah battle of the sexes yeah would you
like to see the same weight class and
everything yeah
why why hard no jio uh for me because i
just don't feel comfortable i'm too
[ __ ] old school i think i'm like too
traditional but what if the girl's
beating the guy
that's tight but then the best time like
that's cool right but then i think the
minute that i start seeing a guy
going towards a girl i just don't like
it do you think girls stay in the place
no i feel the cards and the numbers [ __ ]
off get out of this cage and hold
[ __ ] round three dude you just got
exposed dude cancel geo hashtag cancel
geo
they're gonna do it dude don't do it
please don't do much
that canceled jill she thinks women
should just only be in [ __ ] bikinis
comfortable huh
what yeah i just it just makes me feel
uncomfortable that's awesome well it's
already
i mean what there's a reason why i've
seen a chick kick his ass like
who you can watch all of that i like
watching girls beat up guys
with you that like the guy's now hitting
the chick full force i'm just like no
two people
have you guys seen this category of porn
where these girls like
guys and they do mma fight you know i do
it's one of the funniest [ __ ] things
i've ever seen in my life
this girl is just grabbing this girl's
head and just shoving into her [ __ ]
he's like
and the lake is grabbing
it could be girl on girl guy on the girl
two girls one guy it's
hilarious you should watch it guys do
they wear
cups they wear cups to protect their
balls so you cause girls would should
like
because i feel like they're they would
get their ovaries messed up or something
like their uterus could get
all damaged but not if you got abs girl
yeah but even if you wear a cup it still
[ __ ] hurts really bad
but will it damage your sperm huh you
don't need a cup oh i have this ability
to make it go inside immediately
on site watch you do a kegel for your
balls
it just goes he knows how to tuck it in
wait do they fully go up
what like when you're cold and stuff
like does that happen to your oh turn
into a [ __ ]
yours goes into a [ __ ] 100 but like the
actual like testicle and
it gets really so it when it's hot it's
nice and loose and when it's cold it
looks like a walnut
yeah but like are the actual testicles
still on the outside of your body when
it's cold
it looks like a droopy ceiling like when
it's been raining and it's kind of soggy
it looks like that yeah have you seen
have you seen the videos of the [ __ ]
when a pipe burst in an apartment and it
just starts to sag
that's the ball it doesn't get like
flush but it's like
yeah yeah it gets pretty in there but
it's not fully that's cute
it's like i gotta hide it's difficult
especially if it's really cold
like if you're in some ice cold water
it's like a dehydrator your dick becomes
purple
when you when a guy goes swimming that
[ __ ] everything gets small dude
yep
it's super tiny like [ __ ] microscopic
not me though
have you ever watched kcp after he came
out of the ocean why
why would she do that baby let me see
real quick because you know that straw
trick
where you go like this and you put on
water and it starts growing
wait what what oh that one yesterday and
then you put the drop of water it starts
going like this
so when you're when you're when your
dick is so frozen right like this
[ __ ] there's so much foreskin
and then now you're trying to peek
it's like
[Music]
and then
you're welcome it's like a body
temperature thing like if your body's
hot your ball sack drops so it doesn't
actually have to be
the the area so if you're hot internally
it's like it's it regulates itself
that'd be so fun it's like a nest your
ball stack's a nest it has it just
naturally regulates the temperature
it really is oh the thermostat yeah it's
on eco mode it's on eco mode so when you
go to a
a little tide pool and you touch a scene
enemy it goes like this yeah
the ball sometimes you do that too you
too you touching both
and the balls do that too the ball spins
oh it spits at you too
but you got to keep the whole you got to
keep playing with it [ __ ] male parts
are [ __ ] ugly though
they're really [ __ ] ugly i've learned
to like them
would you ever call a dick beautiful i
prefer a man part over a chick part
yeah flip chick party yeah there's so
many [ __ ] weird things down there i'm
like really cuz
so we swim naked all the time what do
you have to say wait tell me first
before you say it out loud no nothing so
we start naked all the time right
and then when we're like examining each
other's bodies when we're swimming i'm
like
i'm never doing that my my balls and
dick is just not
i don't think it's aerodynamic it's not
made to be like a
flopping in the water it looks like they
grabbed someone else's parts and threw
it on your body
like you're all it's like a picasso you
already look like
you look like a uh like a superhero
already like aquaman like you know like
you just haven't
just why'd you pick aquaman well like
wonder woman or something wonder woman
like everything's nice he was trying to
put it in the ocean
like everything is nice and smooth like
jason momoa i know
you look like jason my body looks like
hers with the octopus between my legs
wait what what is going on right now
like what the [ __ ] is going on
this was just roasting the [ __ ] out of
his wife right now it's like
baby you look like a muscular ass man
dude when you're swimming
for some reason your [ __ ] [ __ ]
starts dating out like a dick and it
just starts while
like the human form like when a guy and
a girl dives into a pool butt naked
the girl looks so streamlined and like
it's ready for the nature and then the
guy
it's like that with like an extra like
rooster
i mean because one looks like a gorilla
in the ocean and the other one looks
like a dolphin
yeah so it's different did you guys see
that seinfeld episode where
uh [ __ ] jerry seinfeld had a
girlfriend who always liked to be naked
and he found out that he actually
doesn't like it when it goes naked all
the time
because it looks weird when like for
example there was a part in the in the
show where he was opening she was
opening up a jar of pickles and he just
sees [ __ ] that he doesn't want to see
so you know she's like doing this on her
[ __ ] butthole opens up he's like oh
[ __ ]
a little [ __ ] weird that's funny i
had a boyfriend that always needed to be
naked and
i got really overwhelmed was he held a
buff though no oh then why
you want it to be free i can't sleep
naked
i don't know i don't like it i i don't
like like
skin touching yeah same i don't like
clothes yeah
i think i feel like somebody's gonna
crawl up there i need to be covered
oh what about like a spider underwear
and then i could do on people i have to
have underwear
well yeah i just don't like the breeze
going up there then i'm like i'm feeling
like spiders could get in there or
something just blows on it real quick
you